on les interpellations dont l' enquête
sur l'assassinât du préfet erignac et
huit personnes sont toujours entendus à
la division nationale antiterroriste à
paris
quatre autres personnes ont été en
revanche relâché aujourd'hui à ajaccio
les auditions centré autour d'un relevés
téléphoniques qui auraient révélé la
présence de plusieurs nationalistes
corses près de l'endroit où l'ancien
préfet a été assassiné au moment des
faits explication pierre didier en trois
jours
les policiers avaient interpellé treize
personnes en corse du sud dans la région
de cargèse et hier autour d'ajaccio
vendredi 8 des interpellés ont été
transférés à paris où ils sont placés en
garde à vue dans les locaux de la
division nationale antiterroriste seul
quatre personnes ont été relâchées 3
ajaccio et une femme à paris parente
d'un des hommes toujours placé en garde
à vue sous l'autorité de ce commissaire
roger marion les policiers de
l'antiterrorisme s'intéresserait tout
particulièrement à un des hommes
interpellés vendredi à son domicile
alain ferrandi de source policière il
est tenu comme un homme clé du dossier
erignac
ce nationaliste de 39 ans est notamment
interrogé sur son emploi du temps au
soir de l'assassinât du préfet des
relevés d'appels téléphoniques
indiquerait que le ferrandi et d'autres
suspects se trouvaient le 6 février 1998
à proximité du lieu de l'assassinât
ce qui n'était pas d'épreuve
fondamentale ya quelques mois semble
nous aujourd'hui nous est proposé comme
des vérités intangibles techniquement
dans une petite ville comme ajaccio ou
le leu les grands axes d'ajaccio
quelques centaines de mètres maximum un
petit kilomètre le borgne des portables
qui identifierait les personnes
pratiquement quelques mètres près pour
ne pas dire et quelques centimètres près
me semble une interprétation à usage de
grandes cités de grandes villes comme
paris ou visiblement ça peut passer mais
pour la corse en place par les
enquêteurs soupçonneraient également
ferrandi d'avoir été en contact avec
jean castela enseignants bastié mise en
examen pour l'attentât de strasbourg
contre l'ena les deux hommes étant
présentés par des sources policières
comme les chefs d'une des six danses du
flnc canal historique
reste que jusqu'à maintenant une seule
personne est mise en examen par le juge
bruguière dans le cadre
l' enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac il s'agit de mathieu filidori
soupçonné d'avoir rédigé des textes de
revendication
philidor et qui nie farouchement son
implication dans l'assassinât du préfet